frank luntz is a pollster in washington
d.c who advises the republican party his
real job is working for google and
promoting oxycontin in the middle
of an opioid epidemic whatever you think
of frank luntz he's great to live with
to share a toothbrush with we know that
because kevin mccarthy does it
how much does he pay for that it's a
question we had asked because there are
of course
rules in the house about accepting gifts
at under market prices
well we learned that kevin mccarthy paid
fifteen hundred dollars a month to live
in frank lunz's apartment
that sounds fine until you learn the
apartment is 7 000 square feet and it's
a penthouse
mccarthy spokesman defended that saying
that that's
fair market rate because mccarthy is
renting only one of
12 bedrooms in the apartment it's only
400 square feet
so i guess that means that he doesn't
use the kitchen
or the living room it's just a 400
square foot bathroom
it gives the term friend and family
discount a whole new meaning wish you
would a friend like frank luntz
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else